Here's a question - Why do we get goosebumps?
And is there a way we can take that knowledge,
and turn it into money?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - with yet another
scientific invention that proves just how
awesome - and simultaneously terrifying - the
future will be.
A research team from South Korea has developed
a sensor, capable of measuring goosebumps
on the human body in real time.
The way it works is, they place a conductive
sensor on the surface of the skin - so when
a person develops goosebumps, and their skin
buckles slightly - it creates a drop in the
electrical charge that's stored in the sensor.
That allows researchers to precisely measure
how big the goosebumps are, and how long they
last.
Now why would something like this be useful?
Well, goosebumps are a physiological response
- but they're also an emotional response,
so being able to measure someone's goosebumps,
is a gateway to information about their emotional
state.
It's kinda like the final frontier for biometric
monitoring.
Obviously, not everyone's gonna be wearing
one of these things all the time - but in
certain situations, like film screenings - it
could allow marketers to see exactly which
parts of a movie people respond strongly to.
From there, you can imagine personalized advertisements,
music, and tons of other services - catered
specifically to the user.
The film industry has been doing something
similar for years now - albeit, without this
technology.
But audience reactions to test screenings
have often informed the final edit of a movie.
So being able to harness that information,
in a precise, measurable way - could be extremely
valuable to both marketers and advertisers.
Potential dystopian future aside, this article
got me wondering - about why humans even get
goosebumps.
What purpose do they serve?
And how did they become a part of our biology?
Well, it turns out - they're a gift from our
animal ancestors.
And like many of the things we've inherited,
they serve no modern function whatsoever.
Beneath the surface of our skin, there are
tiny muscles, called arrector pili muscles,
that attach to each individual hair follicle.
When you're especially cold, those muscles
contract - creating tiny depressions in the
skin, that cause everything around them to
stand up - including your hair.
Goosebumps actually get their name - because
they strongly resemble the way a bird's skin
looks - after its feathers have been plucked.
Of course in animals with thick fur, this
kind of physiological response makes total
sense.
When their hair stands up, it creates an added
layer of insulation around their bodies, allowing
them to retain more heat.
Goosebumps are also the reason that animals
hair tends to stand up when they feel threatened.
That, in combination with the stance they
assume - makes them appear bigger and more
threatening to enemies.
Obviously, this reaction is useless for us
humans - because we don't have thick layers
of fur.
Well, most of us don't.
But we still experience goosebumps, so what's
causing them?
Well, it boils down to adrenaline, the stress
hormone.
Animals release adrenaline when they're either
cold, or under stress.
It's what prepares them for fight-or-flight
situations.
Humans experience the same thing - but in
more kinds of situations.
When we're cold, when we're afraid, when we're
under stress, or when we're feeling strong
emotions - all of those responses cause our
bodies to release adrenaline.
And one of the hallmark features of an adrenaline
rush - is the contraction of our skin muscles.
Hence, goosebumps.
Aside from the fact that they serve no modern
purpose for humans - they're still one of
the most obvious indicators of our current
emotional state.
Now whether or not companies should be harnessing
that information - is a topic of much debate.
So I'm curious to know what you guys think.
Could technology like this, be used for good?
Or is it just another way for people to sell
us stuff?
Feel free to leave your responses in the comments
below - and as always, thank you guys for
watching!